There's a different person. I will send you my labs when I get them all back, but two weeks ago my
hemoglobin was up to 9.3. Every hemoglobin should be over 12 usually, but you don't really get
concerned until it gets down into the 8th or the 7th. And today it's down to 8th. So, of course,
you know, low hemoglobin is probably your best indicator for teens. So hemoglobin is a part
of ademia. So, in different types of ademia, you'll have low hemoglobin, low red blood cells, low B12,
there's all, there's different types of ademia, but the ademia that you get with cancer is called
the, it's called ademia of chronic disease. That's actually the name of it. But with cancer, it has to
do with multiple things. But one of them is that cancer can be gobbled up your iron and
causing anemia. Cancer can be causing leaning, causing anemia. Cancer can, the cancer there is
like chemotherapy and radiation can cause. So, the rest of this person's question, I'm still taking
the supplements you put me on, but would radiation knock it down? Is there anything else I could be
doing? So, this person just had radiation and yes, radiation is a major cause of anemia. So,
an radiation can knock that down. Now, once you're done with radiation, your body will build that
back up usually. So, you don't really need, but there are some things you can do to help pull the
radiation out of your body, and there's some further questions that we'll touch on those in just a
second.